good morning mr fellow norman fowler
served as health secretary from 1981 to
1987.
there is now a danger that has become a
threat to us all
it is a deadly disease and there is no
known cure he was the architect of one
of the uk's most high-profile health
campaigns aids was emerging as a deadly
global threat the idea was to shock the
public into taking preventative action
if you ignore aids it could be the death
of you i think it was probably one of
the most successful
public education campaigns uh since the
war
lord fowler was giving evidence to the
infected blood inquiry he was challenged
on the messaging of the campaign and the
effect
it would have had on those infected with
hiv through the use of contaminated
blood products was any consideration
conscious consideration at least given
to on what the impact might be on them
at this already vilified
cohort you have to make some choices and
the the greatest the choice was first
and foremost to actually
prevent this epidemic going even further
and further faster
jason evans lost his dad in 1993
after jonathan became infected with hiv
and hepatitis c through contaminated
blood products
he was one of thousands of hemophiliacs
and bleeding disorder patients infected
in the 70s and 80s in the nhs scandal
what sort of impact would an advertising
campaign like that one have had on your
father and your family my mom's told me
stories of him being at the funerals of
his friends
and him saying i'm going to be next i
know it and eventually
he was next but
that fear of knowing it compounded by
the government saying you're going to
die
you were ignorant the falling tombstones
the lilies
it was just
i think insult to injury is putting it
really lightly
the inquiry will continue to hear
evidence into next year but after
waiting decades for justice the infected
and the affected might feel their search
for answers
is getting closer ashish joshi sky news